would that be great if you just get to
be join the foursome just get in there
where's Berkeley in Sam Jackson make it
the foursome lots of questions and I
know who has the answer for it
the man who when I think of Las Vegas
and Thanksgiving together I think of
Ernie Johnson
is this your first Thanksgiving in Las
Vegas Nevada
you're gonna go what's happened there
before stays there before I thought
that's okay so walk me through a Charles
and Sam Jackson a part of the broadcast
what's what's the broadcast gonna look
like here walk we like it I have no idea
what its gonna look like but I know
they're gonna be on they're gonna be on
for an hour before those before the
match starts oh by the way it's
presented by capital yeah I mean I could
have guessed with the two of them if I
go more than 42 seconds without saying
Capital One get a buzzer or something so
I'll say it anyway and in the power
Darren Clarke and Peter Jacobsen and I
will call will call the match I believe
and again and finalized tomorrow but I
believe we will have access to Charles
once the match has begun so if he wants
to sure about something while they're
walking you know the fairway to their
next shot we can always bring to be the
host of the pregame show which
everybody's Mike okay Dylan like the
caddies in like the big day for me I'll
be staying out of the way you know
that's you know when my dad and I used
to watch sports together and my dad
being a broadcaster for so long I he'd
always be sit here
oh geez give it a rest take a breath
yeah [ __ ] that's I never want to be
that guy that you're thinner and shut up
please and so we want to hear what Phil
is saying to his brother Tim what Joey
LaCava is bunkered at I go about what
the players might be saying to each
other and again going in those side
challenges like that you know Phil did
yesterday match even started and we've
got we've got what do you called drones
out there I mean it's gonna be it's
gonna look different than watching your
basic tour and I think because we're
gonna be so up close and hearing and
seeing everything it's gonna be for a
ball nut I mean it's gonna be it's gonna
be a blast to watch so when somebody
says I'll bet $100,000 i birdied the
first hole and the other guy says we
call that a challenge now on the weekend
lines they're going to eyes that they
heard in the match and some pretty bit
back and forth and I think they're going
to be some wines that you find for use
that next day people will watch the ball
that bad yes so I think I can't wait to
hear with the kind of conversation is
well unless you're at the forepaws
Casino & Spa in Vegas I'm assuming
you're not yet in Vegas based on what
I'm hearing the background right now
Ernie who is that dog was a pooch rich
I have a we have a beagle and we have a
beagle with it mix Pocahontas Pocahontas
and Bo and yeah they're running around
here and guess what that's been did way
I'm pitching the price and turkeys here
today because we're going to have an
early Thanksgiving and and then I'm
going to leave tomorrow morning first
thing you get out to Vegas about the
10:30 in the morning and that's and
that's to go all that's to call the
match between tiger and Phil presented
by presented by who
Ernie today and my family is actually
having Thanksgiving today and
Thanksgiving tomorrow Wow because we
have so many people who live around here
so yeah it's gonna be a blast you fly
your turkey by the way no we don't do
the fried turkey no rich you don't know
what you walk me through it Ernie walk
me through it well it's done in 45
minutes and institution juiciest joke
you ever had but I'm like man Ernie
Ernie I'm on a statin I live in the land
of gluten-free you know what I'm saying
I mean I guess this is the different
coasts so what I'm saying be careful
Ernie I don't know who's second on the
depth chart to call the the match
between tiger and Phil presented by
right I mean so who's second on the
depth chart they're trained okay
turn our Ernie Johnson at Turner Sports
EJ here on the Rich Eisen show I guess
I'd be remiss if I didn't ask you an NBA
question are you concerned about the the
war
whatsoever Ernie Johnson you had things
to happen every now and that I don't
think it's you know what part of it
people want to see them look vulnerable
you know they want it to be and it
probably does because they don't want to
say okay this pencil man is the chance
again they're like big that they've got
a great team they do need their pieces
and and step is planned you know he's
probably often the best parts of his
life this year and now he's sitting down
and you know you had the Greymon throw
him I'll be I'll be fine and I last time
I checked with names in the decision
something like there so you know I'm not
pushing the panic button at all because
I'm - and Simon is the match presented
by Capital One well if you saying that
people want to see the volt Warriors
look vulnerable
they're certainly giving the people what
they want right now you know when
somebody is that good you want to see
them challenged and you don't want to
just see the trophy to them and I think
something like this happens and it's
like okay well maybe there's more to
does this but but I think they're
healthy with the fetid spill that is
still beating in the end here so okay is
your turkey frying sponsored by anybody
is it a nun sponsored turkey frying
later on today involved in it because I
want you to sit around and and we're
depending on your refreshment that might
be this ball syrup okay no I didn't mean
what did you know my my ring doorbell
just went off and I thought you could
hear it no I think it's somebody cool
ringing to see what's in your wallet
Ernie I think that's what it is
somebody's is calling all
and it's and it's at tea time is noon
local so three o'clock Eastern all on
the air two o'clock upon the air at two
o'clock Eastern and we're and the match
begins at 3:00 or there abouts I think
killing tiger get out there in the
starter Susan you're gonna have to carry
up with somebody we don't have any
cables off you won't you people are
together but ya know it's gonna be it's
going to be interesting first time
they've ever they've ever played match
play and I didn't see children yep and
and I think and I think it's talking
about you guys you can still get the
ball off the course very well and
they've got a face and shadow please the
probably boots back and I think I think
it'll be a birdie fish I look forward to
it earning I really do we'll be watching
we'll be watching just checking it out
the match tiger versus Phil on Friday
presented by thank you sir you know I
just figured out I'll get in look we're
all part of the 18 t community right
here only you you row in one direction
I'll roll with you you know I'm saying
have a great time with your family Ernie
and then safe flight safe journey to
Vegas enjoy Thanksgiving in Vegas and
then Friday's Friday's a match play on
that's a report love and if you don't
see me on camera decorating a match on
Friday it is just here in Iverson don't
see me on camera this assumed that there
was some fun intended splash the element
of danger will have come into play
[Laughter]
thanks brother thanks right back atcha
that's Ernie Johnson that Turner Sports
EJ one of the best three-time Sports
Emmy winner Ernie Johnson the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience